saturday you may not know this is
national bowling day and giving us some
of his spare time huh is kirk reed to
talk about it he's the director of
marketing at brooklyn bowl las vegas how
you doing i'm good how are you it is
national bowling day on saturday you
guys have all sorts of celebrations
coming up tell people if you haven't
been to brooklyn bowl it is one of the
coolest places
yeah this weekend is a perfect chance to
check it out
friday night we have half off bowling
and one dollar chicken wings we're
famous for our fried chicken and known
for our bowling so enjoy both on friday
night and on saturday we have a concert
with r b singer banks which is going to
be really cool and fun so coming down to
brooklyn bowl this weekend you have
framed it well uh also this weekend i
know i've got i got more of these
characters
stay tuned uh even if there isn't a show
you guys have cool things friday you
have half price bowling right yes half
price bowling one dollar chicken wings
uh live dj it's gonna be super fun
everyone's gonna be dancing grooving on
the lanes on the dance floor if you
haven't been you gotta check it out this
weekend it is it is a great place to
hang out great food and just lots of
activities the bowling of course is some
of the best how popular is bowling
nowadays um it's getting more popular
honestly we've seen an uptick uh and
people coming out to bowl and then you
can do that with our restaurant our food
our concerts we offer a pretty unique
experience being able to do all three in
the under the same roof yeah yeah people
can strike while it's hot
so also this weekend what else you got
coming on uh yeah we have an awesome
calendar coming up with with shows
gimme gimme disco is becoming one of the
hottest disco parties in the city we
have that coming up we have a couple emo
nights uh in conjunction with when we
were young festival um and got the disco
night like yes give me give me disco you
got to check it out that is so fun all
right hey kirk thanks for being here
thanks for putting up with the pines
thanks for having us and uh it'll be a
great weekend national bowling day
mercedes
i'm trying to get my mind out of the
gutter